6
25 on your wednesday morning what are
the best ways to get around that big
squeeze on the 95
515 east of the spaghetti bowl well
because of the big traffic
impact of this project i hope you don't
mind my heartburn on it because my goal
is to see fewer cars jammed up in the
two-lane slowdowns in both directions
and the freeway
no for southbound drivers to completely
avoid the work area here's what i'm
recommending get off the freeway
before the spaghetti bowl i mean i'm
talking about as far back as decatur or
valley viewer rancho
heading down to charleston or up to
washington
and then using surface streets avoiding
the spaghetti bowl go all the way over
to eastern
that's where you can work your way back
onto the 95 550 now for northbound
drivers delay's probably going to reach
charleston so that's probably a good
place to get off
and head west avoid the spaghetti bowl
you may lose some time in surfer street
traffic but
might be might beat the headache of
staying in the rolling parking lot of
the freeway
and plenty of options for getting back
on the 95 from charleston
avoiding the spaghetti rancho valley
view even decatur
and don't worry about trying to remember
all this or write it all down you can
review it in the online version of this
and all our stories at our website
8newsnow.com
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8newsnow.com